you say cyrus est bien pour cet épisode
de rien du tout ces épisodes au juste je
vous parlais ce que j'apprends que ça
fait très longtemps qu'on sait pas
parler alors peut-être que vous n'avez
pas sans pression puisque vous me voyez
quand je fais une vidéo mais en fait
quand je fais une vidéo c'est une sorte
de personnage c'est toujours quelqu'un
qui présente des choses et c'est pas moi
directement et là c'est quand je vous
parle comme ça c'est très rare mais
c'est moi directement donc et je sais
pas j'avais l'impression que ça faisait
très longtemps que je n'avais pas parlé
directement
donc j'espère que vous allez bien
j'espère que tout va bien et où je
voulais vous paraître deux trois trucs
qui était important je vais revenir
d'avoir sur ma dernière vidéo donc dans
cette série des candidats aux
présidentielles est là derrière il doit
vous a pas trop plu en tout cas pas à
tous et au début parce que ça m'a un peu
heurtée je crois et après en fait j'ai
compris et j'en suis j'en suis désolé
annoncé ça l'a effectivement comme vous
êtes 33% à ne pas l'avoir aimé du tout
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses dans
cette vidéo donc bon alors il ya le fait
que hier six candidats en une vidéo ça
je m'en suis expliqué au début et
j'aurais peut-être dû prendre plus de
temps pour l'expliquer pourquoi je
pourrais pas je pouvais pas faire
autrement avec le planning que je
m'étais fixé que en gros en rouge aurait
pas pu faire 11 vidéos du même poids
pour chaque candidat
il aurait fallu que je me prenne bien en
avance et chant c'est un truc que j'ai
voulu j'ai pensé beaucoup plus tard il
ya un mois où j'étais quand même mois à
l'étranger
donc je n'ai pas en france je ne pouvais
pas tourner ses vidéos là à l'avancé et
vous en plus quand c'est comme c'était
ton à l'avance je n'avais pas tous les
noms des candidats qui allait se
présenter que c'était enfin bref il ya
eu beaucoup de raisons je veux pas
rentrer dans le détail de chacune des
questions de donc de temps mais aussi de
moyens parce que chaque vidéo coûte
parce que je passe seul à travailler
dessus
voilà et pas mal de choses mais je pense
que ça à la limite tout seul
ça aurait pu passer si cette vidéo là
était bien en fait le problème c'est que
cette vidéo là-bas dedans je rigole
dedans je dis des choses qui sont
fausses mais repris dans les
commentaires sur un solide notamment
et tout ça ça a donné l'impression que
je m'en bats les couilles
alors que c'est faux je m'en bats les
couilles mais effectivement avec du
recul je comprends totalement que c'est
ce qui se dégage de cette vidéo et j'en
suis désolé je suis désolé du coup pour
toutes les personnes qui ont pensé ça et
que ça alors t'es quoi effectivement la
phase où je rigole par exemple j'aurais
pu me débrouiller peut-être pour la
retourner
même dans un même si elle n'est pas ce
même si c'était pas dans ce décor la
tempe il a retourné au calme
je sais pas je sais pas comment j'aurais
pu faire mais en tout cas ne pas la
laisser comme ça dans la vidéo et je
ferai tout mon possible pour pas que ça
se reproduise
pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas les
couilles n'hésitez pas à continuer à
vous en pâte les couilles ça me dérange
absolument pas aux trucs dont je vais
vous parler je vous en avais parlé vite
et dans l'onglet community alors je sais
pas si l'anglais community to monde a pu
le voir on ya accès ou si c'est juste
pour mobiles en tout cas c'est un onglet
où je peux vous poser des questions ou
parler de certains trucs etc
et je vous ai parlé de cette chaîne mais
je ne m'arrête pas parlé encore en vidéo
c'est une chaîne que je fais que france
tv éducation s'appelle quelle histoire
cyrus est en gros l'idée ch pas de
prendre un concept d'actu donc par
exemple les faits qui nous la
robotisation la séparation des pouvoirs
la trahison et c'est plus ou moins lié à
lecture est il expliqué avec un
background historique et parfois
philosophique et c est en fait à chaque
fois j'ai un ancêtre qui vient et viale
ancêtres en discutant on apprend des
trucs et c'est à ça s'adresse à une
cible qui est légèrement plus jeune que
vous mais ces faits de sorte à ce que
vraiment chaque épisode parle à tout le
monde
et normalement vous êtes vous apprenez
ou un truc dans chaque épisode les
retours que j'ai qualitativement sont
hyper cool donc je suis très content
merci à tous ceux qui me font des
retours dessus ça me fait vachement
plaisir ça me touche
on est 5965 dessus donc n'hésitez pas à
aller faire un tour à vous abonner et à
checker les nouvelles vidéos quand ils
sortent une à une par semaine c'est un
projet qui me fait vachement plaisir
puisque france et l'éducation à celles
qui sont derrière c'est pas sorcier etc
et c'est pas sorcier passé
grosse inspiration pour moi c'est un des
trucs qui a fait que j'avais lancé coup
de fil il ya maintenant trois ans et
demi plus donc
donc voilà n'hésitez pas et n'hésitent
pas à checker une dire ce que vous en
avez pensé
ces deux versions plaisir parce que je
suis très fier je suis désolé pour cet
éclairage qui est très clair obscur
c'est un petit peu le côté mais il de
force be with you je voyais le star wars
day à tout le monde
juste pour dire demain chaque vidéo qui
n'a rien à voir et ce que je fais
d'habitude c'est une fiction c'est un
délire c'est un juste un délire
et enfin dernière chose je serai au
bordeaux qui festival qui ce qui se
déroule du 25 au 28 mai donc moi ce sera
le 27 28 je suppose le week end à
bordeaux et je voulais aussi prendre mon
pour rien merci parce que c'est souvent
à la fin d'une vidéo à la va-vite
extra-large un moment avec vous donc
j'en profitais pour exprimer ma
gratitude et donc bah merci merci d'être
là
merci de d'apprécier mon contenu un
merci de me soutenir
ça ne fait ça me touche ça me touche
vraiment love beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
et pis beaucoup aussi on a besoin des
deux ciao